if your world was overrun with zombies
that have metal cages around their
hearts what would you do your safe
Fortress has now been overrun with flesh
eating monsters and now your only other
safe house is on the verge of being
destroyed I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the zombie castle in kabaneri of
the iron Fortress Battle of unato these
citizens have no idea that they're about
to get turned into flesh-eating zombies
a mysterious virus has mutated countless
of people all around the world into
Cabernet zombies and now the only humans
left who have not been turned have now
built fortress-like stations to protect
themselves from these monsters but
they're losing ground to the company
zombies every day ikumo here is a half
human half comedy hybrid who saved his
friends after their Hometown got overrun
by zombies six months ago or in our last
video go check it out now with these
people on the Run they live inside of
this iron Fortress train to go find a
new home past these mountains on the way
there they come across the city of unato
but that's when they noticed that there
their luck has just run out and they
realize that they've arrived right in
the middle of a terrifying five-year war
between these Allied Forces and the
cabinet this place is a battlefield but
if they don't clear this city they'll
never be able to make it to their new
home alive okay story time this dude got
bit by a kabade but managed to stop
himself from turning into a zombie and
then somehow turn into a half zombie
half human matcha KitKat looking type of
thing and then he went through some
crazy [__] with these folks not really
important but the important thing is
they're all best friends and on the run
and are looking for a new safe home to
live in but these zombies are absolutely
terrifying they're not like your regular
zombies that are just flash they have
metal cages around their hearts which
makes killing them all that more
difficult and they're quickly spreading
across the country and this means that
taking back this city is absolutely
essential if they want to reach their
destination but while they were on their
way to getting there these guys did
everything wrong and messed up in two
critical areas if I were them I would
from the get-go have not entered unoto
station right away I would have used way
more caution as this was a known zombie
infested area because while yes this
train station is is an absolute Beast
the iron Fortress but it's still
vulnerable to being overwhelmed and its
maneuverability it's a train like all
trains it relies on a simple train track
which means we've easily could have been
blocked off or some of the track could
have been destroyed by falling buildings
or and this is our only Safe Ride
letting people get off of it willy-nilly
like they did here next to this Lake was
really stupid as hell I would have first
entered that area with a selected team
on foot and get a better sense of the
surroundings before sending out our
strongest team member who is also a half
human half company hybrid to mume she's
a real sweetheart and I would Center up
this Mountainside and get to Higher
Ground as soon as possible this would
have allowed us to get an Overlook of
the general area and be able to see over
greater distance that is what I would
have done before ever allowing anybody
off of the train like they just did here
and this boss babe jumps off the train
and saves the locals in this Warehouse
as I said before her name is mume and
she just like ikuma is another human
kabaneri hybrid and she quickly kicks
ass and takes Naaman is a little
irritated that nobody bothered to put
some guards at the rear good job guys
the iron Fortress parks nearby and all
the returning characters princess I'm a
kudosu and all these other good people
that I'm not gonna bother say their
names about but here they are they all
get out to help the allies and take back
this city princess Aimee tells everyone
that the only way to get past this city
is to go through it but that means they
must do whatever they can to make sure
that the city of unato doesn't fall to
the Cabernet zombies and worst news
arrives they get word that more zombies
are breaking through unato's front line
mume quickly tries to get there and
takes off more hordes of zombies along
the way but suddenly some company
attacked this guy and one of them traps
mume right here where she stands oh my
gosh this has just got a whole lot worse
how this city is handling this war shows
that these people are in for a rough
time because this city is doing
everything wrong and moo made getting
fudge isn't even the main problem here
that's just an anecdote it's noted that
while this city was trying to employ as
many men onto the front lines as
possible what just happened in this
Warehouse was a classic example of
resource mismanagement especially at a
time when the cabane are their most
vicious and their most powerful some
soldiers should have been already been
stationed at the Arsenal Warehouse as
this is where all the city's weapon are
being made and repaired and this fact
for obvious reasons makes this Warehouse
one of the most important assets to this
city if mume hadn't showed up this place
along with many others would have been
destroyed and this would have very
quickly left this city without any
defenses at all if I was unato's most
sexy leader I would have at the very
least had a little bit more foresight to
this situation and put some defenses at
all times around the most critical areas
of the city that are critical to
sustaining this City's life the city of
unato should have prioritized the most
obvious factors like supplying the
population with food and providing them
with a home and shelter the safety of
its citizens is another element that
should have been addressed better and
from this we could have figured out that
while we're talking about safety we need
to be able to protect them with weapons
which means we need to keep the makers
and Facilities of those weapons also
safe from harm the leadership at unoto
could have done a better job and would
have prevented mume from having to waste
your time trying to save these
facilities that clearly should have
already been protected to begin with
about to lose her grip he come out the
star of the show really shows up and
saves her just in the nick of time as
Heroes do and these two work together to
save this man from being eaten by this
meatball Zombie Thing and they blast it
to Hell after saving the train ahead of
them for now ikuma finds out that mume
isn't feeling that great and neither is
he it's strange but he thinks it's
probably nothing that was a mistake he
didn't realize that this is a sign for
terrifying things to come but then he
gets harassed by some of the local Town
folk who tell him that his zombie
humankind isn't welcome here and they
tell him that he'll never be able to
save this station that if he gets out of
line they'll kill him where he stands
but then he notices something odd right
in front of him and he sees thousands of
zombie footsteps all headed in the same
direction the mountains that doesn't
make sense why would the zombies act
this way it's not the usual behavior and
it only gets worse he tells moomy that
the cabernets that they just thought
seem to only want to kill people and not
feed on them this change in intent is
key before they were doing it out of
hunger and now they're attacking out of
Rage shocked he quickly writes down all
of this down in his notebook but
suddenly has another massive headache
and realizes that all the headaches have
only gotten worse since they came to
this city okay this is big news we gotta
report this we gotta tell somebody the
company have been shown to retain some
form of basic intelligence like
displaying basic ambushing tactics and
hunting humans for food however ecommer
has stumbled across something and is
wondering if these creatures are
beginning to kill out of anger and that
is a very bold statement to make as this
would completely change everything we
know about them and while we don't know
exactly how their brain operates we can
get a sense of how they operate by
observing their movements and mannerisms
and by comparing them to something that
we do know much more about and that
would be animals because these zombies
in a way are like animals they behave
more similarly to animals than they do
actual humans because the fact is is
that the combining as a species are less
efficient than us and that prevents them
from being deep thinkers and this means
that like many animals the kabane don't
have the capacity to display more
complex emotions like killing someone
out of anger and they're likely still
killing people out of their natural
innate desire to feed ikuma is on to
something then we have to look into it
it could be that ichima is both right
and wrong right that the Cabernet are
doing something differently but wrong in
that their starting to develop complex
emotions it's even more likely that
they're being led by someone or
something later mume passes the day away
and hangs out with one of her friends
and she tries to make a gift for ikama
her friend wonders if she has a crush on
our main man but mume tells her to shut
her mouth because no way does she have a
crush on igma that stud but she has no
idea that her love will ultimately cost
her everything the next day ikama finds
a shortcut to the castle he heads to the
military headquarters to tell everyone
about a shocking Discovery but that's
when he bumps into mume excited she
tries to give him her gift and declare
her love but he tells her that they
don't have time for no cute anime
[__] right now he then runs off to
meet with his crew and the military
while mume stews in her rejected love
and walks off walking into this tent
everyone hears discovering how to take
down the Comedy Castle this Castle used
to belong to the city but now has been
taken over by the Cabernet zombies and
they formed a zombie nest and is the
reason why they haven't been able to
defeat these hordes of zombies but this
General mustache man tells everyone that
you know has a secret weapon now that
they've taken back a little bit more of
their City they are now within range to
use the military's high-tech mortar on
the castle and plan to blow it all up
and in doing this will also free up a
new train path and will allow everyone
even Ecommerce crew to pass through the
general tells everyone that the special
mortar will arrive in four days from now
but in the meantime the Army will
advance closer to the castle and bomb
part of its structure to weaken its
defenses and he tells the town folks to
get to work on repairing the damaged
train tracks leading up there okay we're
getting whoa whoa hold up they think
they have all the cards and have figured
out the enemy I know from where they
will likely strike from but as we can
tell from past examples this Zombie's
disease has the ability to keep
surprising us and how it mutates if I
was them I would for starters not assume
that we know everything about these
creatures and honestly they should
listen to me we've been on the iron
Fortress we've encountered Cabernet
creatures in the past like a fused
colony which is a nightmare to deal with
it is basically a giant monster made of
millions of interconnected combinate
fused together and one might and also
these wasatori kabane which are combine
that basically retained all of their
previous physical memory from the past
basically Warrior memories which makes
wasatory kabane even more lethal the
point is this virus is showing us that
it has the potential to mutate in crazy
ways which means we don't understand
fully our enemy and the other thing I
gotta bring up is the footprints that we
saw earlier and how these Footprints
could indicate that the zombies could
attack from a route that we aren't
prepared for but I'm not going to bring
it up to them right away nah screw that
idea here's the thing if I'm ichima I'm
a happy comedy hybrid and most of the
military in this room doesn't trust me
to begin with and based on my appearance
it means that everyone here has already
has a preconceived notion of what I am
who I am and my trustworthiness the
military has had bad experiences with
Cabernet zombies and since we are half
zombies this means that their personal
resentment towards company has started
to affect their logic and they're not
going to believe whatever I tell them
because I'm not fully a human I'm not
one of them which unfortunately is not
entirely their fault it's just the way
our brains are made up at this point
lives are at stake in this city which
means that the emotions from everyone
here will be as high as hell so you know
what I'm going to do I'm going to have
princess I am may tell them she will
reveal my findings and will have her
convince the military of what she saw
because I'm not going to take any credit
doing this will increase the perceived
value of art information based on the
fact that princess IMA is viewed higher
up on the totem pole that I am and this
would allow us to change the military's
plans of attack and hopefully get them
onto our side through princess Aimee
because while in theory we could do our
own thing working together at a time
like this is going to 100 more likely
lead to a better outcome these two local
Builders tell the general that this plan
is risky as hell but this Gimli military
guy tells them that they don't have time
to come up with a better plan once the
snow starts melting the cabane will be
able to move in much faster and everyone
here will be even more screwed they'll
quickly get overrun ikuma then finally
steps in and tells everyone his shocking
Discovery based on the direction of the
carbonate footsteps and how they weren't
spread out all over the place but they
all went in One Direction he thinks
there is a chance they might attack from
somewhere else other than the front line
like for example from the rear everyone
thinks he's crazy but he begs them to
listen to him he thinks the kabane are
being led or somehow mind controlled and
will attack from a path that they don't
even know about he demands that mustache
man station some soldiers in the rear
and demands that he be allowed to
investigate his findings even further
before the military starts their plan
but none of the army trusts him and they
think he's basically a good for nothing
zombie ikima gets pissed off at mustache
man and the military but that's when he
suddenly collapses in pain his headache
has come back and he sees the vision of
the castle ikama thinks this is a sign
everyone tells him to rest up but he
says he doesn't have time princess I am
a quickly apologizes on behalf of ikimov
and tells the military that her people
will calm him down mume shows up again
like a fly that won't go away and she
sees ikuma packing determined to handle
this himself he tells her that he will
go investigate the kabane footprints
before it's too late she tells him it's
too dangerous and wants to tag along but
he misunderstands her and thinks that
she doesn't trust him either moomay just
doesn't want him to die but that's when
ikama suddenly goes full on zombie and
he attacks mume and tries to kill her
and during the chaos the two of them go
out onto the street and the whole
village sees him going crazy including
these guards knocking her out ikima
prepares to rip the flesh right off of
her sweet neck
this just went from bad to worse this
was entirely the fault of our two
beloved Heroes mume but even princess
Aimee it's also her fault not only did
the princess not stand behind ikama in
the slightest she paid her respects to
the older generals here way too much the
military not trusting ikama and his
instincts which they should have
listened to him by the way caused him to
lose his [__] and now he's about to kill
mume princess Aimee at the very least
should have ordered kurusu to follow him
and make sure that he doesn't do
anything stupid but also I gotta bring
something up about mume I mean I get it
she's in love with our hero ikema all
you gotta do is tell him you know what I
believe you I will go with you and make
sure you don't kill yourself that simple
plus you would earn some major brownie
points with ikuma and doing that would
have prevented ikima from franking out
he would have not zombified on her
probably and they would have left to try
and figure out what is going on if she's
feeling headaches too along with ikima
she should have told princess ayame that
hey yo I'm feeling some headaches and I
felt fine before we ever came to the
city but now I feel some major migraine
problems then you know what would have
happened princess Aimee would have seen
ikama collapse on ground and go that's
weird two of my half cabinet zombie
hybrid Warriors both have migraines this
is a little too weird to be a
coincidence because think about it right
now they're in a new city they don't
know anybody they don't have any friends
all they have are the people that are on
the iron Fortress everyone on there is
on the same team they're currently
inside a base where nobody trusts any of
them and any slip up they have means it
affects all of them just like igma did
just now freaking out in front of the
leadership of unato city is probably
going to cause them problems he should
not have done that what the both of them
should have done would have been to go
to princess Aimee say yo we have
headaches but also we need to check out
what's going on with these foot tracks
and princess I'm I should have said hey
you know what I'll cover you to see
what's going on that's what should have
happened in short the lesson to all of
this my good weebs is that while
everyone on the iron Fortress is a total
badass they really suck at the
communication Department ikimo ready is
his nasty zombie mouth and it aims right
at mume Sweet throat but suddenly he
freezes in fear he sees the tears
streaming down her face which causes him
to snap back to his humanity and he is
completely shocked at what almost just
happened disappointed mume tells igma
month and he might as well kill her
because she doesn't want to live in a
world where he's dead and now he feels
really bad and he tries to comfort her
but suddenly these soldiers rush in to
capture him just as his gang here shows
up gee you showed up in the nick of time
everyone here thinks he's turned into a
comedy zombie but ikimo quickly shouts
all of them down and tells them to put
him in three days solitary confinement
if he doesn't turn into a zombie by then
then that means he's still human Out of
Nowhere mustache's Man shows up and
tells his men to do what ikuma says
taking him away ikimo yells out to mume
and tells her he'll come back to make
her happy when this is all over but she
ignores him and walks away the next day
kurusu and Princess amay practice
beating the [__] out of each other and
they talk about ikama kurusu says that
ikuma has never been wrong before about
the kabane and that he might be on to
something and she thinks he might be
right they then decide to look into
ikuma's findings and discover something
huge an old mining tunnel leading from
the terrifying Castle into the city this
is how the Cabernet have been sneaking
into the main town they quickly begged
the locals to help them infiltrate the
tunnel before the Army and their special
weapon arrives you know what happens
this guy agrees to help them and offers
to to lead them inside and even mume
agrees to join in on the hunt but that's
when they suddenly find a hidden door
covered in this membrane lock and they
realized that the kabane have purposely
hidden this entrance from being
discovered it's suspicious as hell and
everyone here thinks there's no way that
these flesh-eating creatures could have
done this by themselves but that's when
they hear the Roar of an arriving train
the distance it's the Army's mortar
train and it's arrived ahead of schedule
which means everyone here screwed the
Army gets ready for the battle of the
century ahead of schedule princess Iron
Man quickly goes to meet with mustache
man and demands to know what's going on
he tells her that since the train has
arrived early they might as well attack
unoto Castle now within the next hour
and he orders her to prepare her iron
Fortress to assist them in the rear of
the battle this is not going to turn out
well this battle is about to be a
bloodbath because I'm spotting way too
many signs that tell me that the
military over here has no clue what
they're doing if I was Princess iama
here I would first try to prove to them
that rushing in with their only Ace in
the Hole this mortar is super risky the
train just got here and gimla Guy
mentioned that they wanted to rush this
battle before the snow around them melts
but let's be honest waiting a day to
assess the situation before sending in
the mortar won't destroy the military's
plan but rushing into attack right now
might just do that another thing we must
notice is that they sent in one mortar
train and that's a problem because the
entire military's plan relies on this
one freaking train to save all their
problems now while this mortar looks
totally badass as hell but you know what
maybe we should have explored the
possibility of maybe getting more of
these mortar trains because they look
super useful and the very least they
could have done would have been to call
for an escort of some kind it's also
noted that they wanted workers to fix
the tracks leading up to the mountains
so the mortar train could get closer to
the castle but in reality they should
have worked on this while placing War
trains behind the workers to guard them
while they worked on fixing most if not
all of the train tracks leading up to
the castle I would also likely reinforce
my decision to comment on how stupid
mustache man's plans were by telling him
what we just saw in the old mining
tunnel because this entrance is how the
kabade have been sneaking into the city
causing havoc and then retreating this
further proves ecoma's case that someone
has been leading these creatures and
would likely put the military onto high
alert because honestly at this point
princess anime is behaving like the
biggest pushover in the world and is
exhaustingly annoying back at the mining
tunnel army soldiers finally arrive at
askamume what the hell is she doing here
but that's when they suddenly hear a
loud bang and Sinister moves coming from
behind the mining door knowing what
auras lay behind that door mume quickly
tells everyone to get back but it's too
late the hordes of Cabernet zombies
finally burst through and quickly
overrun some of the men mume takes pot
shots from up on this hill and uses this
moment to sneak past the swarm of Comedy
sneaking into the tunnel with one
mission in mind to take out whoever is
controlling these zombie bastards while
swarms begin to surprise attack the city
nearby the locals try to fix the train
tracks when some of the workers begin to
get nervous they think they hear comedy
sounds coming from nearby but this
Soldier tells them to get back to work
now within firing range the Army's train
prepares to fire their special mortar
cannon firing the first shot they
realize that this Castle is stronger
than they thought but they did damage it
and they prepare to fire a second round
meanwhile back in town the soldiers
walking ikima begin to hear that the
town is getting overrun by carbonate
zombies and that mume has snuck into a
mining tunnel alone ikima is shocked and
demands to be let free telling them that
he can help but these soldiers begin to
panic and think that he's starting to
zombify again and they think that him
and mume are working together with the
cabinet they shoot at him causing ikima
to get really pissed off and he breaks
free of his chains and walks right on up
to the soldier reaches his hand out and
grabs the gun instead of the man
stunning the soldier and probably making
him feel like a total idiot and super
guilty and so ikma takes the weapon and
heads out to save his girl and the town
meanwhile mume presses on inside of the
mining tunnel and that's when she come
across this terrifying horde of Comedy
zombies she fights them off and barely
passes through and barely misses a booby
trap and out of nowhere she falls
through the floor and begins to realize
that she might not be able to save the
town without her man ah classic anime
you never fail she hears some footsteps
coming towards her and sees that it's a
vicious carbonate but this one looks
more terrifying and different than the
rest back at the tunnel the military
prepares to fire a second round but
that's when this mysterious kabanero
fires two sniper rounds from the castle
hitting the Border Cannon but nothing
happens but that's when they hear the
rumbling armies of kabade Crash through
the bushes nearby and quickly swarmed
the cannon and the train using their
Collective heat they melt the Cannons
and the Allies quickly tried to fire off
a final round but it's too late and
everything explodes mustache man tries
to drive the train out of there but gets
overwhelmed and eaten alive while the
train falls off the Mountainside it's
glorious back underground mume tries to
fire at the cavity but she's no match
for it she tries to escape but isn't
quick enough desperate she reaches for
her gun in the distance but gets kicked
into a wall knowing she's about to die
she hides behind this rock and thinks
she's safe but that's when the cabinet
begins to push and she quickly realizes
that she's about to get crushed alive oh
as much as I love mumei's character she
really did everything wrong I don't mean
from when she entered the tunnel but
from the moment she fell for our main
Man mume rushed through inside of the
tunnel the moment she couldn't rushed in
like Rambo without a care in the world
and yes it's obvious she is very capable
but her rushing proves that she wasn't
thinking clearly and she didn't stop to
think that she might just run into
something more dangerous the closer she
got to the zombie Hive Castle which is
why she should have had someone else to
travel with her from the main team
because honestly there was no need to
rush the city's already getting burned
to hell so they might as well take their
time by running into this next level
Spider-Man 2099 type of company it shows
the closer we get to this cabinet Castle
the tougher and tougher these monsters
will become and now that she's by
herself in unfamiliar terrain she's
really not setting herself up for
success mume is certainly not acting
like any really cool boss babe that I've
ever seen But if I was a five foot two
little girl and I would have known that
there would have been one card left that
we could have played it's noted that our
fall down here just lasted about three
and a half seconds which means that we
fell approximately 51 meters down now
it's clear that from the looks of things
we aren't as strong right now so we
probably couldn't jump back up from
where we fell but the time that we hit
that second pipe to when we landed on
the floor was only about 1.8 seconds and
this fact is good news for us because
this means that at that distance that
second pipe we hit would have only been
around 5.7 meters above our heads and
this means that from the get-go after
seeing how terrifying this monster is I
would have tried to reach those pipes
that would have been within reaching
distance and we could have used that to
scale the wall back up from where we
came from Mumbai yells out for ikima and
her last moment thinking he won't show
up and you know what happens he does he
shows up at last minute and swiftly
kills the cabinet and mume runs to him
and they hug it out and he tells her
that they'll never separate again but
weirdly enough ikimo's back begins to
Glow bright green moving on meanwhile up
at the mountain the locals continue to
try and fix the tracks but gets Wort
that the military Train nearby has been
destroyed and they get ready to retreat
but they hear the swarm of kabane
footsteps charging towards them and they
all get ready to die right here but
kuzru and his team show up and help them
hold them off and Princess Aimee finds
out the ikima has escaped and is headed
inside of the carpetent castle to go
after the leader apparently this
mysterious sniper dude she tells
everyone that they need to go help him
and stop the man controlling all of the
comedy but gamely guy over here tells
everyone that their plan has failed so
they should Retreat and Princess Army
finally develops some cajones she steps
up her game walks over to this man and
tells him to grow a freaking pair and
know what it works she convinces him to
stay and the rest of the survivors
continue to fight on back in the cave
ikima and mume try to figure out what
the frick happened with his back and
they also realized that their painful
headaches have also disappeared and just
then they get found by one of the
teammates and he hands ikima his
signature kabane slaying weapon reunited
with his Squad they attack unato Castle
from different directions the rest of
the Town folks also join in and
everybody works together it's a real
sweet moment and they use this missile
from the iron Fortress to blow a hole
through the Castle's front door and they
head on inside heading into this room
they notice a blinding blue light
shining above them and they see a
freaking kid inside what that's when one
of the locals gets shot and ikama
notices the sniper from above they
quickly hide and the local guy
recognizes him he tells the group that
this guy was known as the Lord of unatov
station and that he was supposed to be
dead and he tells them a little guilty
secret five years ago during the fall of
unato station the Lord got bit by kabade
but somehow he didn't die he turned into
a kabaneri instead but the people didn't
know what the kabaneri was they tried to
kill him and in doing so almost killed
daughter causing him to lose it and
forced him to turn his daughter also
into a cabin area and now this guy's
trying to take over unato station out of
Revenge and won't stop until he kills
all of the humans here they realize that
his daughter is the one inside of the
blue Cocoon of light and ikima begins to
recognize this light it's the same color
as the time when mume was in the heart
of a fused Colony some time back and
they realized that this Castle is
actually a nest to a fused colony and
once this thing bursts it will turn into
a terrifying comedy monster and won't
stop until it destroys the world the
gang gets ready and prepared to destroy
the [__] out of this thing but suddenly
they hear a loud roar erupt from the
cast of the egg is beginning to crack
this local guy desperately tries to talk
some sense into Lord unato but he almost
gets shot again and mume uses this
opportunity to fire her gun and she
disarms the bad guy quickly climbing up
the castle she battles it out with the
kabaneri Lord unato and shows off some
really slick moves and he tries to shoot
her again but she deflects the bullet
and it hits his daughter suddenly a
flood of memories from the Cocoon flood
into mume distracted Lord unato has
about to kill her but she gets saved by
the local dude knowing this Lord from
years ago he begs him to be a good guy
but this Baddie is like nope and stabs
him through the chest ikema then loses
his [__] and tag teams him with mume
battling it out mume realizes that this
bad guy can't be saved and critically
wounds him making him fall down below
and that's when sniper Lord's daughter
sees her daddy fall and she also loses
her [__] the Cocoon then bursts open
fully and the whole Mountain begins to
rumble [__] goes south real quick and
mume can tell that this monster is
actually crying and it's afraid and deep
down she is just a scared little girl
who watched her dad who is trying to
protect her fall to his death just
kidding but sniperlord is about to fall
to his death for good but he gets saved
by a local guy and everyone here quickly
gets out of the crumbling castle and
they witness the entire Mountain turn
into what they all feared a fused kabane
Colony okay this is some crazy anime BS
right now the very thing we all feared
has happened a fused Cabernet Colony we
all seen one before in our previous
video and it was super scary and messed
up it's basically millions of kabane all
coming together to form a big big giant
monster think along the lines of an ant
colony and all the worker ants views
together to form a freaking giant super
ant scary nearby Princess ayame and the
iron Fortress kid news that the train
tracks have now been blocked by this
scary monster she quickly gathers
everyone and tells them to retreat but
it's too late the fused Colony spots
them and begins to charge right at them
and begins pulling on the train from
behind it tries to destroy everyone here
but this super smooth train operator
girl quickly comes up with a plan and
tells everybody that they'll shake it
off once they get through this tunnel
but there's a problem they're going too
fast and they will need to slow down
before they come out of the other side
of the tunnel or else the train will
derail train girl and her friend quickly
come up with a solution and ready the
emergency brakes and she tells the squad
to shoot the monster now Manning the
Cannons they blast this thing off just
before they go through the tunnel
causing the monster to crash into this
wall as it explodes the train pulls on
its emergency brakes while everyone
inside holds on to dear life and they
make it safely to the other side and
survive the entire town that notices the
sky rained down blue snow particles
falling from above and they think that
the spirit of the Cabernet girl is now
resting head is at peace the local guy
nearby holds sniper Lord in his arms as
he watches his former friend calmly
drift off into the fiery pits of Hell
later the gang celebrates bodyguard
kuzuru tells lady I am a not to risk her
life in battle next time because she
could get hurt and then she sort of
makes him kind of nervous with her
cuteness and it is super cute outside of
the train ikuma and mume talk about how
the carbonate virus increases anger
anxiety and hatred but what suppresses
the virus from taking over the world is
love he tells her that one day they'll
find a cure but until then she shouldn't
worry about him turning evil anytime
soon he then shows off the gift that she
made for him earlier because he finally
took the time to listen to her and take
the gift and she gets super excited and
even makes an excuse to walk near him
cheeks blushing she suddenly plants a
big kiss red on his mouth this freaks
him out but it makes her super excited
and everything and everyone is all
hunky-dory and Happy and they continue
on with their journey to find their new
home but what do you guys think about it
let us know what you like about the
video and what you didn't like about the
video don't forget to like subscribe
leave a comment down below please and as
always don't forget to check out our how
to be playlist